so I said that today we would talk about
contested or brokered Democratic
National Convention what that is what it
means what the implications are what the
math of it is and as we get into that I
do think it's important to understand
that the reason a contested convention
is worth discussing is that in practice
it would most likely be used for the DNC
to select an establishment centrist
candidate now it's it's interesting to
know about contested conventions no
matter what and how it works but in
practice I don't want to hide the
context being in 2020 that it is a
mechanism which could be used to deny a
progressive denomination and allow
Democratic Party insiders to select
whichever their centrist of favorite is
at the time that we finally get to the
convention so I don't want to hide that
but I don't feel the need to bring it up
throughout the entire story so I just I
want to get that out of the way so the
way that the Democratic nomination works
differently than the Republican
nomination is that to secure the
nomination you need a majority of the
delegates meaning 50% plus one or 1991
1990 would be half the delegates you
need 1991 to secure the nomination
that's 50% plus one if nobody secures
the 1990 plus one delegates from the
primaries which are then voted on in the
first round of the convention then you
have what is called a brokered or a
contested convention there's a second
round of voting which happens after
negotiations often behind-the-scenes
between candidates with their delegates
and something called super-delegates are
allowed to vote now super-delegates back
in 2016 were allowed to vote on the
first round this is why in 2016 you
often had you know Bernie and Hillary at
different points with roughly the same
number of pledged delegates secured via
elections via primaries but then you had
plus super-delegates the vast majority
had expressed support
for Hillary Clinton and that is why from
a very early point you saw these numbers
with a massively lopsided lead for
Hillary Clinton in 2020 as of right now
the super-delegates can't vote on the
first round super-delegates are widely
known to support establishment centrist
candidates so it is likely it's not
guaranteed but it's likely that if
nobody gets to 1991 delegates adding the
super-delegates for a second round of
voting would likely hand the convention
to an establishment centrist it's
unlikely that if you allow
super-delegates in they would go
overwhelmingly for Bernie Sanders or for
Elizabeth Warren so now it's very early
right so why on earth would we now be
talking about a brokered convention
we've only had two primaries Iowa and
New Hampshire that's very true but the
primaries so far
combined with the polling start to point
us towards a contested or brokered
convention again unless something
radically changes so this is about odds
there's no way to say right now we will
or we won't have a brokered convention
there's not even a way to say that we
could be 80 or even 90 percent certain
one way or the other but with every
passing day the polling is split among
so many candidates with every primary
we're three four or five candidates get
some delegates with the addition of
likely delegates for Tom Styer in South
Carolina and Michael Bloomberg in some
of the Super Tuesday States the odds of
a brokered convention continue to go up
and the really important element to
understand to all of this from a
strategic perspective is that this is
asymmetrical if the goal is to prevent a
specific candidate from securing the
nomination then you have an asymmetrical
situation where Bernie needs to win on
the first round but anybody who doesn't
want Bernie merely needs to deny Bernie
9 1991 delegates I've used the football
analogy before if you're winning by
seven points the offense needs a
touchdown
you only need to prevent a touchdown you
can get them all the way down the field
you can allow a field goal you can doall
as long as you prevent the touchdown you
win and thus you have an asymmetrical
situation it's very similar with Bernie
Sanders Bernie must get 50% plus one of
the delegates to get the nomination
because on the second round he is very
unlikely to do it the DNC insiders the
establishment merely have to prevent
Bernie from getting 50% plus one that
stacks things against Bernie Sanders
mathematically okay
case in point look at the five thirty
eight.com estimates right now as of
right now five thirty eight estimates
that Bernie Sanders has the 52 percent
chance of winning the most delegates
before the convention a plurality of
Delegates more delegates than any other
single candidate but only a 36 percent
chance of winning more than half this
would deny Bernie the nomination while
Bernie would still have a plurality of
the delegates so now let's look at the
math of this kind of at the big picture
level we will use our pool of three
thousand nine hundred and eighty pledged
delegates thirty nine eighty remember
you need half of that plus one that's
nineteen ninety plus one if the race
remains roughly the way it looks right
now from the national polls through the
primaries this is just our first
estimate you would expect for example
Bernie Sanders polling twenty three
point six nationally that would be
equivalent to roughly nine hundred and
thirty nine delegates Biden would get
seven sixty five Bloomberg five 65 war
and four ninety four and so on down now
in this scenario Bernie gets the most
delegates a plurality but it's not a
majority and thus he doesn't get the
nomination now an astute viewer will
notice this is too crude an estimate
because remember that most primaries
have this 15 percent viability threshold
so if you don't get 15 percent in a
particular primary you don't get any
delegates so in New Hampshire Elizabeth
Warren got 9.2 percent of the vote but
she didn't get nine percent of the
delegates she got zero delegates because
her share of the vote didn't make her
viable so over time the voting in any
one state
consolidate in some states candidates
could end up with a higher share of the
delegates than their vote total for
example if you look at New Hampshire
Bernie won twenty five point seven
percent of the vote but he got thirty
seven percent of the delegates because
of that viability threshold Amy
Klobuchar got twenty percent of the vote
in New Hampshire but she got six
delegates that's twenty five percent of
the delegates the non viable candidates
end up sort of subsidizing a higher
share of the delegates to the candidates
that do meet that 15% viability
threshold so this is a crude estimate
but I think you get the idea
with every primary we can fine-tune our
mathematical expectations in Iowa nobody
got more than thirty percent of the vote
and none of the delegate recipients
dropped out in New Hampshire no
candidate got more than 26 percent of
the vote and none of the delegate
recipients dropped out or are likely to
drop out anytime soon and remember that
this is self reinforcing the more it
looks like nobody will get to fifteen
fifty percent of the delegates the more
other candidates are incentivized to
stay in to see what can they bargain for
when we get to the convention that
possibility becomes more appealing to
other candidates when it doesn't seem
like anyone's going to get 50 percent
plus one this could actually get
significantly more split than it is now
making a brokered convention even more
likely because remember Tom Stiers
polling like 18 in a new poll in South
Carolina he's likely to be another
delegate recipient that would again
split the vote the delegates further
Michael Bloomberg despite the racist
audio that our friend Ben Dixon released
is polling in the mid to high-teens in
Florida and Texas which would be another
candidate getting delegates so this is
the math of how a brokered convention
even at this early stage seems to be
developing and it is asymmetrical
warfare in that if you deny Bernie the
nomination then it's wide open for the
establishment to pick whoever they want
in the second round of voting at the
convention so we'll of course be
following it will update the math with
each passing
primary but this is conceptually why
it's already something that's being
discussed one of our sponsors is privacy
comm they're giving you $5.00 when you
sign up for their completely free
service at privacy comm slash Pakman
I've been using privacy for a little
over a year now you've heard me talk
about it before it's a lifesaver and
here's how it works takes just a couple
of minutes to set up anytime you buy
something online or on the phone instead
of actually using your real credit card
number the privacy app and the browser
plugin let you give each company a
randomized virtual credit card number
that you create out of thin air it'll
even autofill the card number with one
click and the payment is taken out of
your checking account without the
merchant ever knowing your real
information so this allows you to keep
your banking information secure but also
to take control of your finances you can
create up to 12 of these virtual credit
cards a month you can set spending
limits you can freeze them you can
delete them any time you want so when
you do this it means you're not going to
be charged when you don't want to be
because you can destroy the virtual card
number right after using it which for
instance I love using free trials
because I know I won't be charged when
the trial is over if I use a virtual
credit card number you're keeping your
identity private by not telling
companies who you are you're keeping
your bank or credit card info protected
against data breaches and identity theft
and it's free there's no catch
whatsoever but if you want privacy also
offers a ten dollar a month plan that
gives you one percent cashback and lets
you create 36 credit cards a month and a
twenty five dollar a month plan tailored
more for small businesses where you can
create 60 card numbers a month and much
more but definitely go ahead and at
least get started with the free plan
you'll protect your financial info
companies can't charge you unexpectedly
and like I said you'll get five dollars
to spend when you sign up at privacy
calm slash Pakman